je souffre énormément dans le végane une
jeune femme dans le copain est appelée
mortellement par une voiture continue de
lui écrire à son ancien numéro de
téléphone on tenait à ce que tu es un
téléphone j'en ai déjà mais ce numéro a
été réassigné à robe un journaliste qui
a traverséos tombe rapidement sous son
charme pour le conseiller dans sa
romance il peut compter sur une alliée
de taille Céline Dion dont il doit faire
le portrait pour son magazine
dans le film Céline conseille le jeune
journaliste en se basant sur son deuil
de René en plus d'interpréter son propre
rôle d'avoir autorisé l'utilisation de
son catalogue musical et d'interpréter 5
nouvelles chansons céline est l'une des
productrices exécutives du film Dorian
américaine du film allemand coup de
foudre par SMS avec un gros bonus la
participation de Céline Dion ah c'est
quand même Louisiane
est une comédie romantique classique
mais réussi et l'interprétation de
Céline passe le test
arrive en salle ce vendredi
Montréal
[Musique]